atomic Carlo says my IQ is north of 130
yet I question my own intelligence all
the time I feel big cognitive dissonance
between what people expect of me and
what I consider myself capable to do
well you know Carlos what I would
recommend there is that if if you
haven't done it just go do the
personality test that understand myself
calm because what you're describing
sounds very much like high levels of
negative emotionality or neuroticism and
you might want to find out if that's the
case because if you're much higher than
average in neuroticism then you're going
to be questioning yourself all the time
and you might want to figure out if
that's actually a trait and if it is a
trait well then that gives you an
explanation of it and then you might
also note that your levels of negative
emotion are not well matched to your
likely skill now that doesn't
necessarily help you learn to cope with
it but sometimes identifying the reason
is useful and there's another
possibility - is that your mode is
dysregulated and that you're depressed
so that's another thing to consider if
you if you do find that you have high
levels of neuroticism but you're not
depressed then one of the things you
might do is write down all the reasons
like really think them out you know I
mean really get serious about this write
down all the reasons why you might give
yourself more credit for intelligence
than you have and part of that could be
like a really deep reconsideration of
successes you've had in the past with
complex intellectual issues because
imagine that you're serving as your own
defense attorney against a very critical
part of your mind that can help lot that
can help